halo gets a new release date horizon
gets a new release date saints row is
back and so much more my name is davonte
chisholm and you're watching gamespot
news
just in case you missed it earlier today
jeff keeley hosted opening night live a
two-hour showcase that kicks off
gamescom in germany during the event
halo fans got the much anticipated
december 8th release date for halo
infinite's campaign and multiplayer
however it wasn't much of a surprise as
it leaked beforehand the real surprise
came in the form of a special edition
halo infinite xbox series x console
and a special edition elite controller
to honor the 20th anniversary of the
franchise
this december release date marks the
latest ever in the year for a mainline
halo game halo combat evolve launched in
november 2001 halo 2 debuted in november
2004 halo 3 came out in september 2007
halo 4 launched in november 2012 and
halo 5 premiered in october of 2015 but
halo wasn't the only game to get a new
release date horizon forbidden west was
given the date of february 18 2022
during the event the game's director
said in part quote it's no surprise that
our teams were hugely impacted by the
global pandemic we have been adjusting
to new workflows protocols and other
challenges
while keeping our team safe and
prioritizing a healthy work-life balance
pre-orders for forbidden west open
september 2nd and the game will be
available on both playstation 5 and
playstation 4. leave a comment down
below letting me know what you think of
both of those new release dates and your
hype levels for each of those games
but okay so we know both of those
franchises are getting sequels but we
also learned that saints row is getting
a reboot starting from the ground up
the new game simply titled saints row
features an entirely new cast of
characters in a new setting the new
game's tagline self-made suggests the
game will revolve around starting your
criminal empire from nothing as you take
on rival gangs after the debut cg
trailer the studio showed off a set of
quick snippets of gameplay as well
some other quick highlights from opening
night live include the tales of series
we'll be getting a new game on ios and
android seafood's release date for ps5
and pc is set for february 22nd
2022
and a new marvel tactical rpg called
midnight suns is coming soon
oh and i almost forgot split gate season
0 starts today right now and it has a
new map and a new invasion mode
and i just can't wait to play it after
this video is done
remember you can check out all of the
trailers and presentations from opening
night live on gamespot's youtube channel
or at gamespot.com
but before you go do that and binge all
of those trailers let's talk about one
more
non-gamescom related story
like 100 000 warzone accounts being
banned developer raven software's tweet
revealed this bandwave targeted repeat
offenders and cheat providers at the
source
warzone's last ban wave was back in july
and more than half a million accounts
have now been banned for cheating and
other offenses and while these band
waves seem to just be applying a
band-aid to the problem leaving cheaters
to eventually resurface activision has
officially announced that call of duty
warzone will get a brand new map and new
pc anti-cheat system with the
integration of call of duty vanguard
this major update doesn't have an
official date but the new map is
announced to be arriving later this year
presumably some time after the launch of
vanguard this november but alright
that's it for today let me know what
your favorite announcement from opening
night live was and stick with gamespot
for all the updates on your favorite
games and more
bye
[Music]
[Music]
you